bonjour c'est un grand bonheur d'être
devant vous et de revenir maintenant à
l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que la france
socialiste ça suffit la france divisé
ça suffit la france affaiblit la france
moquer tout ça ça suffit maintenant la
république nous appelle les républicains
appellent république et merci à ce grand
jusqu'à revient le député guaino de nous
rappeler la république en chantant ce
chantre de la république qui nous
appelaient pour cette victoire de
giscard en 74
tout ça c'est la même famille il n'y a
que les socialistes qui n'entendent pas
que la république appelle les
républicains écoutez les écouter leurs
discours ils nous disent par exemple que
l'économie va mieux
oui ça va mieux en effet pour une partie
de notre économie qui est exposé au
monde qui vit les règles internationales
parce que le monde va mieux oui ça va
mieux pour tous ceux qui peuvent
échapper aux règles socialistes et aux
lourdeurs administratives de la france
mais mes chers amis vous êtes ici
nombreux
est ce que dans nos départements ça va
mieux
dans quels départements l'agriculture
est elle aujourd'hui florissante dans
quel département
la situation du bâtiment et l
développant dans la situation du
bâtiment aujourd'hui partout
nous voyons des difficultés la
perspective des pme et l réconfortante
non nous sentons bien ce déclin de la
france engagée à londres nos jeunes
veulent être entrepreneur à bruxelles
nos entrepreneurs
être traité et chez nous on accueille
davantage par les guichets sociaux que
par les projets économiques
la france va mal
les républicains ont le devoir de porter
assistance à peuple en danger
c'est à dire pour nous le devoir de
préparer et de réussir l'alternance
chers amis chers nicolas cher alain cher
françois scherr bruno tous ici nous
devons réussir l'alternance
je vois trois missions pour notre
famille politique d'abord
pensons à la france plus qu au pouvoir
les socialistes importe aujourd'hui dans
la république
les pratiques de leur parti il nous
montre le mauvais chemin
ils fracturent la france il oppose les
salariés les chômeurs ils nivellent le
niveau nos collèges il stigmatise les
familles il abandonne des territoires
la france perd la force de sa cohésion
certes il sera toujours possible de
rassembler les français autour des héros
de notre histoire mais il est plus
difficile de les réunir autour d'une
vision d'avenir partager deuxième
mission préparons notre projet avec
exigence et détermination je suis
personnellement convaincu qu'en 2017
nous aurons 12 mois pour changer la
france
ce qu'il sera pas fait dans les premiers
mois deviendra un certain dans la
campagne
nous devrons dire ce que nous ferons
mais aussi comment nous le ferons
quel référendum
quel en donnant ce qu'elle session
extraordinaire pour qu'en six mois
en douze mois la france ait pu se
redresser et que le changement soit
engagé nous avons tous en tête quelques
promesses non réalisées dans le passé je
vous le dis comme une confidence au
point où j'en suis de mon expérience je
préfère que les français nous disent non
un projet de réforme précis et concrets
qu'ils nous disent oui un projet flou
ambiguë et qui ne déboucherait que sur
la puissance la question pour nous le
moment venu sera pas de choisir le bon
candidat les bons candidats
nous en aurons beaucoup ce qu'ils faute
à la france
l'eau non venue c'est un bon président
troisième mission confortons notre
organisation
les républicains les républicains c'est
à la fois une identité mais c'est aussi
un message
ça doit être une force une force
d'organisation pour mener les combats
politiques
oui nous le méritons bien ce nom de
républicains ceux qui comme nous sont
nés avec les républicains indépendants
le parti républicain ce qu'ils ont vu et
revu tout à l'heure les images de la
création du rassemblement pour la
république
nous avons déjà cet adn républicain nous
prétendons pas à ce que tous les
républicains de la france soit adhérent
au parti des républicains
est ce que tous les socialistes de
france sont adhérents au parti des
socialistes
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
les républicains c'est un message que
nous envoyons au pays parce que notre
objectif c'est le rassemblement et le
rassemblement
il est autour de la valeur centrale
celle de la république pour être fort
nous devons être unis je me réjouis de
l'évolution de notre débat politique
interne
j'en remercie le président du parti
nicolas sarkozy j'en remercie tous les
grands leaders de notre famille nous
sommes amis militants en train de créer
un climat où pour l'avenir
nous choisirons pas forcément le plus
bagarreur celui qui cherchera à mettre
plus de deshors nous cherchons tous
ensemble pour la france le plus
rassembleur cette compétition du
rassemblement elle est bonne pour la
france elle est utile un autre parti
alors choisissons toujours le
rassemblement plutôt que la recherche
des affrontements et attention puisque
nous avons des primaires des primaires
qui sont statutaire qui seront organisés
qui seront énergie qui sont transparents
elles nous permettront de départager nos
candidats mais que les socialistes ne se
réjouissent pas de cette procédure
chacun de nous préférera toujours son
second choix au premier choix des
socialistes
nous resterons rassemblés derrière celui
qui sera désigné
voilà la vocation des républicains ce
qui nous intéresse
ce n'est pas la conquête du pouvoir
c'est le redressement de la france
c'est pour ça que notre union et notre
valeur première
en conclusion chers amis un message
personnel un message personnel à la
france cette france qui est tant aimée
dans le monde
nous bénéficions partout en amérique
latine en amérique du nord en asie en
europe partout nous disposons d'un
patrimoine historique exceptionnel
l'image de la france bien sûr elle a été
à plusieurs reprises écornée on a été
moquée quand on a fait les 35 heures ou
un certain nombre d'autres décisions ou
le monde sourit de nous voir si attentif
à rester à l'extérieur du monde
mais au total tous cette attaque un
autre image
so petit à petit redresser et l'image de
la france serait affirme toujours
pourquoi parce qu'elle est fondée
elle est fondée sur les lumières sur la
révolution sur la résistance sur le
général de gaulle sur des valeurs plus
grande que nous et quand le monde entier
a vu la manifestation du 11 janvier le
monde a pensé
regardez les français ils sont à la
hauteur de l'image de la france c'est ce
patrimoine là qu'il nous faut défendre
c'est ça qui est le plus important
et personnellement je viens j'accuse
j'accuse le gouvernement socialiste
d'organiser un grand rassemblement
mondial
la coop 21 entre les deux tours des
élections régionales un moment où nous
devons envoyer au monde entier des
messages de la france
la seule question sera le score du front
national
le seul débat ce sera les alliances
entre les deux tours
on va se trouver dans une france qui
affichera devant les médias nationaux et
par les médias français
les querelles politiciennes
alors que le monde entier attend de la
france qu'elle nous parle de ses valeurs
qu'elle nous parle de ses ambitions
qu'elle nous parle de ses visions
c'est ça le plus important chers amis
pour nos enfants que nous avons à
défendre cette image de la france on ne
peut pas la laisser abîmé par tout ce
qui amena ce qu'est ce qui menace
aujourd'hui la france ce qui menace la
france c'est l'abaissement la perte des
valeurs
le renoncement le populisme c'est tout
ce qui touche à l'extrémisme c'est pour
ça que la doublure et post que nous
apporterons à ceux qui veulent abaisser
la france c'est d'abord que nous
battrons tous ensemble le front national
aux élections régionales et que nous
battrons tous ensemble le parti
socialiste aux élections présidentielles
et ainsi mes chers amis nous pourrons
tous ensemble assumer la mission des
républicains notre mission collective
faire grandir la france